oh he told you he told me okay he said
Christine had a very hard time with it
yeah and did not want Mary to reconcile
with Cody
that's what I was told too what did you
see uh I didn't know this was connected
to it but I guess she was falling apart
she was at my house and she was falling
apart and I feel so bad I don't want to
talk bad about her but I just saw her
kind of flipping out and I didn't know
what it was about do you think if
Christine didn't object that Mary and
Cody would have gotten back together
they would have reconciled and they
would have had a little bit more of a
relationship uh yeah because when Cody
says and thinks that type of stuff it
usually happens
wow
that could have changed the whole
trajectory of Mary's life yeah it sucks
right
that's really absolutely frustrating and
offensive right now there's no way I
would not support him and marry having a
great relationship if that's what they
both wanted that's absolutely ridiculous
but Robin also says that she walked into
the tail end of that conversation so
even Robin kind of knew about it but not
all the nuances surrounding it I think
that there was something that was
twisted in that there's no way I would
have ever felt like that I don't feel
like that and I am so frustrated that
he just doesn't know me that he would
make that allegation
that he would twist my words to somehow
think that I would say anything like
that and that he would say that and
spread that lie is what's frustrating
that's a lie that's not me and I would
never do that
so I asked Christine to clarify but she
really didn't remember the story and she
actually feels that
she would never stop a Reconciliation
between you and Cody
that's nice to know
that that's how she feels yeah I don't
know what happened with their
conversation like I don't know Cody's
perspective on I've never heard this out
of his mouth I've never heard this out
of Christine's mouth
um It's Curious that Christine doesn't
remember anything about it at all so I
literally have no idea but Robin does
remember it Robin doesn't remember it
yeah interesting I think it was a moment
that he wanted to
it's a little heartbreaking to me
[Music]